glory to Ukraine
[Laughter]
foreign
prime minister
but he's done here
Party leaders honorable parliamentarians
distinguished guests
welcome to this extraordinary event the
second joint address to Parliament by
his Excellency
president of Ukraine on behalf of my
colleagues we are honored for your visit
as we come together Under One Roof
we take a moment to celebrate the
friendship and shared values of our
countries
we celebrate our people in the history
of cooperation between Canada and
Ukraine
and we celebrate solidarity
allow me to now invite the right
honorable prime minister to take the
floor
[Laughter]
Mr Speaker
parliamentarians honored guests friends
We Gather today at a pivotal point in
history
this is a time of incredible uncertainty
attacks upon the rules-based
international order threatened to upend
the peace and prosperity that have been
the Bedrock of Canada's success
this is a challenge on a generational
scale a challenge that history will
judge us on a challenge we must confront
with lionhearted courage and the world
can find no better inspiration
and our friend here with us in our house
today president volodamir zielinski and
his wife the first lady of Ukraine Colin
as a lens
[Laughter]
one year six months and 29 days ago
Vladimir Putin launched a full-scale
invasion of Ukraine unleashing a
campaign of violence and brutality that
has left countless dead and forced
Millions to flee
for one year six months and 29 days the
people of Ukraine have defended their
homes their language and their freedom
to choose their own future
they have fought back with the courage
that has inspired the world and they
have been led by President zielinski a
great champion of democracy
in March of last year you addressed our
Parliament virtually
in June of this year I addressed your
Parliament
where I was touched to see so many
Canadian flags in the chamber today you
are able to be here in person to speak
about the fight for your democracy and
your freedom and you do it to remind us
that in your country
Russia continues its assault and
ukrainians are sacrificing their lives
President zolenski we speak regularly
we've spoken about what is happening at
the zaporizia nuclear power station and
the environmental destruction caused by
Russia's tactics we've spoken of the
human toll children kidnapped
and people who are being taught to hate
I've seen Putin's destructive evil
firsthand during my visits to Ukraine
since the War Began
I saw it in the bombed out neighborhoods
and the bridges reduced to Twisted Steel
in the abandoned homes
I also saw it in the faces of your
citizens
they walked down the street sat in cafes
daily life seemingly persisting
but with everyone I spoke to I saw in
the backs of their eyes the weight of
this war
the fear for their fellow ukrainians on
the front lines
the anxiety that another air raid silent
siren would go off at any moment
the loss of a loved one
the toll of this war on the mental
health and well-being of ukrainians is
immeasurable
I know first lady zelenska you are
dedicated to the work to address this so
today we are funding providing funding
to support mental health care in Ukraine
as we continue to applaud your
tremendous leadership in these difficult
times
foreign
rules-based orders
crumble so much is lost
one example of how this breakdown
manifests is the horrifying preventable
hardship as Russia blocks grain exports
worsening hunger and starvation among
the world's most vulnerable people
president zielinski you and the
Ukrainian people are holding the
rules-based order in the balance
you were on the front lines
not just of the fight for Ukraine
but in the fight for the kind of future
we are all going to be living in
rules matter
following the second world war the
bloodiest and deadliest conflict
Humanity has ever known
The Whole World's Nations agreed on a
common set of rules and principles to
re-establish peace
for three quarters of a century these
rules have allowed historic Prosperity
they have fostered trade given citizens
the necessary confidence to invest in
their future and helped millions of
people escape poverty
there isn't a single place that hasn't
known Prosperity thanks to peace
what Putin has done
is a break with civilization it is a
violation of our common Humanity
it is an attempt to disassemble the
rules-based order that protects our
freedom it is a move to weaken democracy
and assert autocracy
Putin governs with deception violence
and repression
he imprisons his own people and stirs up
ugly Sentiments of xenophobia and racism
but his Imperial delusions in Ukraine
have been met with a fierce defense a
defense that is not just strong because
of the support from friends around the
world
but because those who fight for their
freedom will always fight with their
whole hearts
that is why we must all fight by all
possible means
we must speak out loud and clear against
violations of national sovereignty and
of friends to international law
violations to the rules-based
international order must be denounced
and aggressors
must be held responsible for their
actions
that has always been our government's
position
that is why without exception we oppose
authoritarian States and we stand by
those who defend international law
Universal human rights and the ability
of All Peoples to decide on their own
future
that is why we remained faithful to our
principles when Michael korrig and
Michael spaver were arbitrarily detained
by China
there are countries that are bending or
breaking the rules
political forces that are pandering to
demagoguery
and we are all experiencing a rise of
disinformation some state-sponsored some
politically motivated that twists facts
and refuses evidence and science
in this era of uncertainty and of
resurgent great power competition rules
are what will protect us
and it's not enough for them to just be
written down somewhere
we must advocate for them
stand up for them and live by them
history will judge us on how we defend
democratic values
Ukraine is at the tip of the spear in
this great challenge of the 21st Century
that's why Canada and Canadians are
there for Ukraine and why we stand so
unequivocally against Russia
it's why people across Canada have
welcomed with open arms over a hundred
and seventy five thousand ukrainians
some of whom are here with us today
foreign
[Music]
they are part of a group of Ukrainian
scientists who found safety in Canada
and their expertise in the clean economy
is helping the world unwind its
dependence on the fossil fuels
weaponized by despots like Putin
we also have leaders from the Ukrainian
Canadian Community like Russia and
others they come from the Canadian
prairies where so many Ukrainian
immigrants have settled for over a
century and they have led the charge in
helping their communities welcome
refugees fleeing Putin's bombs
everything com collecting clothing
donations to helping them find homes
we're also joined by Agnes and Susan who
lost their brother Anthony a
humanitarian volunteer just 12 days ago
he was killed in a Russian strike while
trying to help civilians in donetsko
Blast innocent people who are being
brutalized by the kremlin's unprovoked
aggression today our Gallery is filled
with ukrainians who've come to show
their support and gratitude for you
valudamir but I think we all need to
take a moment to thank them for their
bravery their generosity and their
solidarity with the values of democracy
[Laughter]
thank you
president zielinski I have clearly said
that our government will stand by you
for as long as it takes Canada has
provided nearly nine billion dollars in
military financial and humanitarian
support to Ukraine since Putin began his
war of aggression today we are making a
longer term multi-year commitment that
provides predictable steady support to
Ukraine it will include 650 million
dollars over three years for 50 armored
vehicles including medical evacuation
vehicles that will be built by Canadian
workers in London Ontario
will also send F-16 Trainers for pilots
and for maintenance so ukrainians are
able to maximize their use of donated
fighter jets
we will continue to work with our
partners including within NATO to
provide unwavering support and we will
continue to provide economic support to
Ukraine over the next year so that it
remains a a strong Dynamic and
prosperous Democratic country
but our greatest hope
is that you won't need military or
financial support for long
and that peace returns soon
but it cannot be a false peace based on
a compromise imposed by the aggressor
for a lasting peace we must oppose Putin
and reject his attempts to bring us back
to a Time
when might made a right a lasting peace
must clearly establish that borders must
be respected regardless of the size of
the neighboring Army this piece must
restore the right of ukrainians to
determine their own future
Canada stands with the principles of
Ukraine's peace formula we believe that
peace must respect the U.N Charter be
based in international law and preserve
Ukraine's territorial Integrity this is
the peace we must fight for
and that is what Ukraine has done
for one year six months and 29 days
Putin thought it would make he'd make
quick work
of marching on Keith
Putin thought president zielinski would
cave in the face of personal peril
sir you have not
you have galvanized the world you have
made the bonds between Democratic allies
and Friends stronger than ever
olena to see you here today in this
chamber to see so many proud and
courageous ukrainians here today after
everything you have all endured is a
testament to the commitment of your
country
and the strength of your fight
president zelenski you have shown the
rest of the world true leadership even
in the most difficult moments
you fight with a sense of hope and you
are dedicated to the security and
progress of your people
in times like this the world needs
leaders who understand that true
strength is not about wielding power but
about empowering others
true strength is not about crushing your
opponent with brute force and lies
it's about respecting the humanity and
the Dignity of everyone it's about
governing from a basis of Truth and
compassion
in times of Crisis holding fast to
positive values like this can be a lot
harder than resorting to fear and
resentment but it is well worth it
when the history books are written we
know what they will say of you
that you were among those who stood up
for their principles no matter how hard
among those who stood up to bullies
among those who protected the less
fortunate among those who unified people
in the face of fear among those who
defended the rules and upheld the law
among those who put Justice hope and
freedom Above All Else
we know that democracy is one of the
greatest expressions of freedom it gives
us the right to have a voice to choose
our own future to be protected by a
system with Justice and accountability
but democracy does not happen by
accident
and it will not continue without effort
we must defend it and strengthen it with
all that we have
a Vladimir my friend you have a unique
understanding of this
stare down Putin every single day and we
will be with you and all heroes of this
courageous fight for as long as it takes
glory to Ukraine
here it is now my distinct honor to
welcome President Vladimir zielinski of
Ukraine to address this house
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
glory to Heroes
thank you so much
um
Dr
ladies and gentlemen Canada
before I start I just want just want to
remind one thing
this thing is very important to
understand both Ukraine and Canada
and what we are up to
what we need to do
and to do together
1983.
the city of Edmonton
is history is closely linked to the
destiny of Ukraine and Ukrainian
Canadian community that here in Edmonton
the first Monument to the victims of
holodomor
was built in the world
[Laughter]
thank you
was built to remember the genocide
against the Ukrainian people the
genocide ordered and
perpetrated by Moscow the first ever
followed more monument in the world
at that time Ukraine didn't yet have
memorials
commemorating the victims of genocide of
ukrainians because Ukraine was under
moscow's control back then
this fall will Mark the Fortis
anniversary is saying that first and
very important
commemoration of the victims of
roladamor
a lot has changed since then
Ukraine gained independence
Ukraine is restoring its own historic
memory
dozens of other countries they are
parliaments their governments have
already recognized all of the more at
the genocide of the Ukrainian people
and this year
this year alone there have been 11 of
such recognitions
and I'm sure that the world the whole
world will recognize the truth about all
the more
but
there is something that has not changed
either in 40 years since the monument in
Edmonton was built or in 90 years since
the whole the more
Moscow now as always is banned on
controlling Ukraine and makes use of all
available means to do that including
genocide
it is genocide
what Russian occupiers are doing to
Ukraine
and when we want to win
when we call on the World to support us
it is not just about an ordinary
conflict
it is about saving lives of millions of
people
literally
physical salvation
ordinary and women
and Men children
our families whole communities entire
cities Russia's destruction of mariopal
of valnavaka or bahamud or any other
city or Village in Ukraine must not go
unpunished
thank you
live
live life life and Justice must Prevail
everywhere in Ukraine and for all
ukrainians
this Russian aggression must end with
our victory
yes
so that so that Russia will never bring
back genocide to Ukraine and will never
ever try to do so Moscow must lose once
and for all and it will lose
Dr speakers the whole parliament of
Canada Dear Justin
Mr Prime Minister ladies and gentlemen
of the government
dear representatives of of all the
communities and cities all citizens of
Canada
in my opinion
one of the most
startling qualities of your country
that Justice is not an empty word for
Canada
another extremely important fact about
you is that you never never ever make a
political bet on hatred
and enmity
and you are always on the bright side of
History
thank you
that's to you thank you so much
during the first world war and in the
time between those terrible terrible
Wars and during the second world war and
during the Cold War you always defended
Freedom you have always defended Justice
and I had no doubt that you would choose
the side of freedom and Justice when
Russia launched a full-scale war against
Ukraine
thank you
but it is but it is Never Enough only to
choose the right side you also need to
be able to be a leader on the side and
you do you are a leader and I thank you
for that Canada thank you
thank you so much
thank you very much for your thank you
very much for your political support for
Ukraine and this is through the support
of a leader and it is global in scale
because when you are fighting for
something when you are fighting for good
in human nature the false neutrality
neutrality looks obviously immoral when
one sees true leaders who are afraid to
be real to speak out to fight have only
two opinions to change
or to be looked down
and I thank you Canada for being a real
example of leadership and honesty for so
many around the world an example that
inspires others to defend life
let the support for Ukraine with weapons
and equipment has allowed us to save
thousands thousands of lives this
includes air defense systems
armored vehicles artillery shells and
very significant assistance in demanding
thank you so much
Canada's leadership in sanctions against
Russia for this war and Terror really
encouraged others in the world to follow
to follow your lead
and I'm especially grateful for your
extremely strong 100 leadership support
of the Ukrainian movement to Nato
for your strong participation in
training our soldiers it's very
important it's already a tradition that
Canada trained those who defend the
world
thousands
yes
thousands thousands and thousands of
pilots during the second world war
thousands of ukrainians now and this is
what makes Victory
Victory strong Victory indispensable
training thank you for this thank you
for your economic support for helping
Ukraine to get rid of its dependence on
Russian nuclear fuel
and this is progress not not only for us
really Ukraine and Canada together with
their partners and really friends are
demonstrating to everyone that it is
quite realistic to completely cut off
cut off our ties with dubious Russian
nuclear technologies
in addition to be purely technological
Danger
the Russian nuclear industry also serves
moscow's political expansion
Russia uses nuclear technology and
construction of nuclear power plants
like gas and oil for political attacks
against the sovereignty of other nations
Russia is trying to break the
sovereignty of other through its
manipulation of energy resources all
energy resources
so the more nations are free from
Russian energy resources the student
energy in the world will once again
become just an energy resource
not a weapon not a weapon against
sovereignties
another important area of our
cooperation literally Justice
today in talks with prime minister with
Justin we discussed the Canadian
Initiative for the G7 to set up efforts
to confiscate Russian assets
those funds that Russian and its
henchmen used to pay for their War
should be used to fairly
compensate for the damage caused by War
and Terror
active
active and Global work is also required
to bring Russia to justice for the crime
of aggression itself and for absolutely
all crimes from this aggression all
death
every interpretation of every child
every adult every life needs to be
protected and every attack Nation needs
Justice to rule
the world needs it to
so that other potential aggressors can
see that war ends in verdicts for the
aggressor
and I urge you Canada to extend your
ability to lead to other countries
especially
in this matter
of Justice
of persecuting the aggression of
compensation for aggression of making
the aggressor feel how strong Justice is
and most of all I would like to thank
you Canada for the purely human thing
for making ukrainians feel at home
when
they are here in Canada thank you
thank you thank you so much
thank you so much
this is you know this is not just a
Legacy of History this is a legacy of
character
the Ukrainian Canadian Community is
about millions of Ukrainian Destinies
that have become the destiny
of Canada with all its
diversity of communities Freedom loving
courage our special inner call for
justice
the ability of our people to share
Comfort wherever they grew to build and
create not to ruin or humiliate
Ukrainian Flags in Canada are a part of
everyday life as absolute trust to
Canada in Ukraine
in fact such proximity provides many
answers including answers to the
question about this war
can we give up
no
can we betray the good and human nature
can we agree to evil
no
can we allow our identity to be erased
Ukraine and Canada are the same we stand
and we fight for Life Ukraine not
genocide will be victorious in this war
people will be the winners not the
Kremlin
Freedom will be the winner Justice will
be the winner you can know this for sure
about us
because you know for sure about yourself
that you would never submit
to evil
Mercy Canada thank you Canada
and may one day soon
a monument a monument be built in
maybe Edmonton
[Music]
as in other cities of the world and in
the cities of Ukraine to honor the
victory of our people in this war our
foreign
victory
common Victory with you with you the
people of Canada with all your
communities with all your Legacy Legacy
of good
ladies and gentlemen
today me and
my beautiful first lady
I had ah
had honor I really had the honor of
meeting with them governor general of
Canada honorable Mary
Simon and she taught me
she taught me a word
from your modern tan
ayurinata
are you inata she said the meaning of
this word is don't give up
don't give up stay strong Against All
Odds
and so
salad beam
are you another
Canada are you another Ukraine
slavocrine
thank you
foreign
thank you Mr President
McDonald's I now invite The Honorable
Adam gagne speaker of the Senate to take
the floor
president
Ms zelenska prime minister Trudeau
speaker Rota dear parliamentarians
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
Mr President it is a great honor and a
real privilege for me to thank you for
your very powerful and very inspiring
words
we are all honored by your presence
the last time you addressed this
Parliament just a few weeks after
Russia's full-scale assault on your
country
you implored us to imagine
what the Ukrainian people were feeling
to imagine what it's like to be bombed
and invaded without provocation to
imagine what it feels like to understand
the meaning of the invasion
that Russia was not only attacking
Ukrainian territory but also it's very
sovereignty Mr President I can say
without hesitation that we have heard
you
your words have echoed in the chambers
of our Parliament and our committee
rooms and offices and all across our
great country
shortly after I became speaker of the
Senate of Canada I was asked about the
importance of role models and I
expressed my belief that if you see it
you can be it
Mr President a new generation is seeing
you
having worked with young people in the
field of education for over 35 years and
as a mother of two male adult children I
am heartened by the model you are
showing
thank you
young people around the world are seeing
that a democratically elected voice is
the real form of power
Mr
President for more than 18 months you
have been the epitome of the people's
mobilization and a source of inspiration
for the world
whether you were speaking from a bunker
or behind a podium in a meeting room or
on the front line
you never gave up
you never gave up wavered or hesitated
embodying the spirit and resilience of
the Ukrainian people
I'm certainly not the first to mention
it but who could forget February 25th
you were in the center of Kiev the
target of the Russian Invader it was one
of the most perilous
and uncertain moments of the war and you
had one strong message to convey we are
here your people have carried forward
this resolve at hostile
and Beyond while we draw inspiration
from their stories we also recognize the
realities ukrainians have faced
withstanding thousands of artillery
rounds every day
grieving the unrelenting loss of family
loved ones colleagues and Neighbors
patiently working through precious
minefields while drones Circle overhead
defending against waves of attacks on
civilian infrastructure
and taking steps where and when they can
to recover and rebuild
Mr President
your people's resilience in the face of
such aggression compels the
International Community in your now
famous words to be here for Ukraine
however long it takes
and our message today which you can
bring back to your people is equally
clear the Canadian people stand with
Ukraine
we aren't going anywhere
on behalf of all senators of all members
of the House of Commons and no doubt of
all Canadians I thank you once again for
your courage and your determination and
for your inspiring words to Canadians
and to the entire world today
Ukraine
glory to Ukraine
thank you madam speaker
Mr Prime Minister
Mr President
as has been noted today you join a very
small group of world leaders who have
addressed a joint session of our
Parliament for a second time
among those leaders one stands out for
his oratory his leadership in the face
of adversity and his strong
determination to fight on behalf of his
people and on behalf of what is right
that leader was the late African
president and Nobel Peace Prize winner
Nelson Mandela
[Laughter]
in his first address to join to the
Joint session of our Parliament Nelson
Mandela said of the Canadian people and
I quote
they are like us like brothers and
sisters
from whose warm embrace we shall never
be parted
Mr President I want you to know that we
feel like that still with Ukraine
I'm confident that you'll share the same
conviction after your visit today Mr
President indeed Beyond metaphor the
ties between Canada and Ukraine are
above all Family Ties
ties between our two people's
strengthened by the Ukrainian Canadian
community
which totals 1.3 million people
your words today also remind us of
another world leader who address both
our houses during the time of War
in December 1941
during World War II the British prime
minister Sir Winston Churchill traveled
to Ottawa and delivered an impassioned
speech on behalf of his people to rally
for the continued support for his
country at War
it was a defining moment of history and
one that must never be forgotten
we have here in the chamber today
Ukrainian Canadians Ukrainian Canadian
World veteran
from the second world war who fought the
Ukrainian Independence against the
Russians
and continues to support the troops
today even at his age of 98.
[Laughter]
his name is yeroslav hunka
and uh I was going to say he's in the
gallery but I think you beat me to that
but I'm very proud to say that he is
from North Bay and from my riding of
Nipissing to miscoming
he's a Ukrainian hero a Canadian hero
and we thank him for all his service
thank you
[Laughter]
at a time when freedom is regressing in
many parts of the world and autocrats
are supporting each other
Ukraine's resistance has rallied
democracies
to action
resistance often starts at the top
when you Mr President
with you Mr President but also with the
berkova Vada where the business of
parliament the people's business
has never stopped
I know that parliamentarians in this
chamber have marveled at the courage and
determination of our counterparts
Ukrainian legislators have pursued their
critical work despite
the continued warning of missiles and
drones
despite the threat to well-being of
their families and homes and despite the
overwhelming challenges of recovery and
rebuilding
throughout this terrible War I have had
the great privilege of developing a
great friendship with my counterpart the
speaker of the verkovina Radha chairman
stefanchuk
like you Mr President he advocates for
his country
with passion and with poise and like you
he has conveyed what is at stake
Ukraine's freedom
but also preservation of the rules-based
international order which is a
fundamental
part of the future of the democratic
world
most recently we spoke at the G7
speaker's Summit in Japan
at that time
he shared with me a drawing from a young
Ukrainian girl
who thanked Canada for our support and
our shared wish to all that all
Ukrainian children should live under
peaceful Skies
it moved me this year's and it moves me
there again
it is moments like these bonds like
these that remind us that almost all
stand with Ukraine in the face of the
threat to its sovereignty
Mr President
Canada has stood with Ukraine people
throughout its proud history and that
will not change
we will continue to stand for justice
and peaceful Skies over Ukraine thank
you once again for addressing our
Parliament
glory to Ukraine